if they put me hijab they would only
detect the test and they said the
following questions do you love your
wife yes pass would you die for her yes
pause if your wife was okay would you
get a second wife yes pass there is not
a conflict between a man loving his wife
and a man wanting to be polygamous I
agree but I did the polygamous part I
get the whole wanting to have more
intimacy with more than one woman but if
you can ask the question
um uh more accurately that take on
another wife and all the
responsibilities that come with another
wife how many men will agree to that for
example if one says oh I sense that
you've got a second wife can he says can
he say no I don't yes you can you can
see that you can say that yes I possibly
believe this is if we sit down and we
talk about it and I take my selfish
needs out of it I.E me one in him all to
myself I need to understand them so I
need to sit down and I need to really
think about how this is going to affect
him it could lead him into doing things
in life because my wife was she also
gave me the um so the feeling that I
could be open with her I told her at one
point that look babe that's the sister
is that you yeah and possibly if we're
talking about secret second wife if my
husband has gone behind my back that to
me is cheating even if it is islamically
correct feminist sisters who love their
sisters who will die for their sisters
will take a bullet for their sisters but
will not share their husbands for their
sisters so the point is this you know
what I mean if you love your if you've
got a good husband by the way I'm not
talking about these guys who don't pray
jahil clowns here who don't pray who
oppress their wives a good man who
practices who fears Allah who's good to
his wife takes care of his wife he comes
and he says I want a second wife all
hell breaks news and then we blame this
man yeah but why are you keeping it
secret what else should you do this is a
test to see how Allah is testing her to
see how she responds yeah that's you
know if she decides to do the opposite
which is you know
um you know throw the divorce card or
throw this card then ultimately she is
falling into the act of Disobedience
which I'm now expected as a Muslim man
to follow it's not the religion of el
Islam it's the religion of woman's
feelings I'm not going to follow that
religion with respect to you I'm gonna
do uh frustration to the collective
hormonal and emotional status of men or
women or children or anybody else you're
saying if he's man enough if your
husband came to you man enough and said
to you he wants a second wife at least
then it's not Secrets
do you know about it are you gonna what
are you gonna do are you gonna say to me
you can thank you your face
if he knows that she would withhold the
kids from him use the state then do it
without knowledge but I believe that's a
form of abuse you said bro and I'll call
them cows who would rather make their
wife happy at the displeasure of Allah
yeah a cow with the biggest cow would
ever that would go and commit Zina
adultery at the cost of my wife you are
the biggest simp ever with a capital s
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be a Sada khajari for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation
you and the shadow American award click
the link and donate what you can
glory and gratitude belong to him
um so just quick uh bitter buzzers if
you oppose anyone just press it you have
one and a half minutes
um let's try obviously not to back by it
or slander I know we're not going to but
just a disclaimer
um and that our honorable sisters our
honorable brothers are here to discuss
something pertaining for the second
because we know there's an attack on the
family unit left right center and
inshallah our aim with that show is to
come to that inshallah to preserve
marriages let's get straight into it the
topic is secret second wives
um and yes the first topic is is it okay
so we're gonna do is two segments the
first one is going to be that is it okay
for a man to be in a secret
um
second marriage or third or fourth
marriage for that let's start with hijab
so let me just summarize the points um I
think when we say is that okay now for
Muslim people at least it will become a
fairly discussion this becomes a Jewish
Prudential discussion Islamic law
discussion so with there's two there's
two components there's the abstract and
there's the application okay the
abstract you can refer to as Fair called
the rulings or the ASL Hokum they would
call it and then you have tanzilla which
is the application right so to give you
an example marriage itself can take
different rulings
sugar can take different routines like
if someone's got diabetes and they take
sugar that can be Haram for them you see
if someone is morbidly obese and they
eat food that can be Haram for them
because it's harmful so even food can
take different rulings even though a
piece of chicken for example or a cube
of sugar in itself is not Haram but it
can be Haram in certain situations yeah
and so there's lots of things like that
in general so when we talk about this
issue here to get straight into it
when we talk about secret second wives
there's no such thing as secret second
wives in Islam because there's no
secrets in the cafe you need to have at
least two witnesses okay according to
the majority of Scholars they're Malachi
yeah they say you don't even need to
have witnesses they say it's mustah it's
not working for the most part that's
that's the sort of thought but they use
the Hadith
you have to you know popularize it to
the people however having said that it
is very possible for somebody to get
married without telling their first wife
in Islam as an abstract talking why
because that is there's no prerequisites
no conditioning there's no conditioning
according to any of the mother in fact
that a man needs to tell his first wife
or give us permission permission from
her or anything like that yeah in order
for him to get a second
practically though the issue is
if he does it then he must now and you
think about it if it's going to be a
completely equal polygamy which is the
hustle of the situation then he's going
to be having to at least divide the
knights equally because in polygamy you
don't have to divide the base equally
you divide the knights equally and the
Knights have a very specific definition
from you know from certain times
now what I'm saying is now the second
wife for this to actually be feasible
where the first wife doesn't know the
second wife must do Michelle really for
the most part is a kind of marriage
where is
that she's she is voluntarily letting go
of some of her rights yeah for going
Horizon
and so if she does that and for example
she says to the man come to me on such
and such a day on there's such and such
a night or such and such a place this is
legitimate in Islam in fact it has an Us
in Islam the prophet sallam I did this
with him she let go of her nights so
it's not uh Haram in fact you know it's
something the process himself
so the question now is okay you've got
other issues like inheritance
because the inheritance changes you do
have to actually change your inheritance
it's interesting because Josie mentioned
this in one of his books but I'll
mention this afterwards of the secret
second one and by the way Scholars of
the past did this they married a woman
without the first wife's knowledge
the big scholar he married a woman her
name was unsie she her first wife she
was a scholar in her own right Hadith
scholar okay
and even some Western academics have
written papers use of Rappaport wrote a
paper about
um the fact that he married a second
wife without the first wife knowing and
he was asking the question why did he
feel the need to do that he was a very
do you want to put it in modern day
terms high value man very rich he was
the biggest scholar of Islam at that
time but he didn't tell his first wife
in fact there's even something
who didn't get married to a second woman
it says that he went into a particular
war or battle yeah and he took a
prisoner of war
and he took a prisoner of war who's very
beautiful but I wanted her as well
okay and then he says
so in the war booty one fifth goes to
like let's say uh the state and then the
adult bait take one fifth of that so
because Alice from Acid Bates he put her
the the jaria in the fifth that he
wanted
so Verizon was very angry because he
wanted to be without
anyway the point is is that what I did
he said he you know he endorsed what I
did
the point is Fatima could never have
known that he did that
because it was far away from Fatima yeah
it was it was not in Medina they were
not in Medina so you've got two things
that Prophet sallam endorsed it
obviously it could be argued that she
wasn't a wife nevertheless it's still a
polygamous sexual relationship and it
was clear that he done a sexual
relationship with her because the whole
discussion about him doing janaba and
Russell and all these kind of things
moreover even the prophet Muhammad
himself I mean
if no one thought about this verse when
the prophet he kept a secret from some
of his wives
some Scholars I'm not going to go into
detail but some Scholars actually
connect this with an incident with Maria
the copt and so on and yeah I'm not
going to go into detail but the idea of
actually
not telling your husband or your wife to
be fair because the Hadith Muslim says
that lying is not allowed except for
three things
one of them is
that when a man speaks to his wife says
and when a wife speaks to her husband
white lives it doesn't have to be white
it can be a black line sorry to say yeah
yeah this this idea of White Lies it's a
modern day thing that people say is this
in the classical works yeah there's no
differential differentiation there here
in the like for example that's not how
to understood it could be you can lie to
your your spouse in this situation the
issue is this is that so can it can they
lie in the context of for example if one
says uh I sense that you've got a second
wife can he says can he say no I don't
yes okay
you can say that yes I personally
believe this is
at least on the Masters
the prophet says you can do it yeah I
believe I believe it's possible now
having said this all
I said this is the abstract ruling yes
but in implementation okay now do
because as I said the hakun can take
different rulings based on a personal
side if someone does this and they get
caught for example or something happens
or yeah
oh she just asks him where were you last
night
yeah but even that you can like right so
you are allowed to lie anything related
to the relationship I believe I believe
I believe it's not anything because
there are some things you can never lie
about in this life yeah for example you
can never lie about the religion of
Islam you can never lie about something
which relates to the rights of the
person you can never lie about something
related to invested interest like the
children for example there's things you
can never lie about but I believe yes
you can but are you saying in the
context of for example it's going to
it's going to ruin the family unit so
he's lying to protect his family I look
I'm saying to you I don't recommend this
but you are we start off by saying that
there's two things there's one aspect we
should use Prudential and another aspect
which is application jurisprudential the
man can do it it's up to the man no
woman can take that right amount away
from the man oh it's impossible so let's
say something is right yeah so that
islamically
any of us can get a secret second wife
absolutely any man for that secret we
can get islamically there is no problem
in a man getting married to another
woman without the first wife's knowledge
however the question is and there's no
there's no Health in this yeah there's
actually I've not seen one solitary
difference of opinion in any of the 14
Generations that's not there any scholar
saying that no a woman needs to know she
needs to tell her it doesn't exist yeah
that's it having said that do I
recommend it no I don't recommend it in
general no we'll come to it why do you
recommend it okay guys
um after this show if you see any of us
dead please come to our generator please
make to offers
we're talking about the religion of
Islam like you know Allah says
I don't prostrate myself to the emotions
of women or men or anyone else I'm
speaking about religion this is a ruling
we cannot distort the rulings
that you know are you going to make
something which is Haram for you Halal
for you Haram because of the fear of
your wise that's a very deep statement
that could that could be uh
exactly yeah so I believe Brothers
should fear Allah more than there why
but having said that you guys heard it
I mean please tell me I I don't think
let me just I think there's Bill meaning
there's consensus that's none of you
guys are okay with your uh husbands
getting a second wife can I just quickly
just get that out of the way sister swad
absolutely not you're not okay but yeah
this is that it's a no for me and if you
have anything to say say it now yeah
um
yeah no no sister Tyler and I won't be
happy with it okay she won't be happy
with okay no no listen now listen yeah
listen now listen to us Brothers yeah
okay starting from double dear would you
say you are polygamous by Nature hey we
had this conversation before can we have
you on the mic please I disagree with
you okay no no I'm just asking a simple
question let's not go into an Integrity
I'm not going to say I'm flicking in
Spanish I'll say that bro bro let me ask
you the question again yeah yeah if your
wife was totally okay with it yeah zero
problems you come back home and she's
cooking a meal bro we just got married
yeah would you get a second wife yeah
okay uh no I'm gonna miss the brother
because
look okay what is that this year we'll
just seeing this within our nature yeah
um if you die we loved you yeah it was
it for the cause yeah okay Brothers okay
what I'm just saying is that as a man
would you not say you are polygamous by
Nature does it mean you have to act upon
it but would you not say that every man
is polygamous by Nature that if their
wives were totally okay with it no
consequences that they would do it
the thing is I work on the doors there's
so many women out there but the thing is
it doesn't do nothing for me no no we
know that look I have no doubt about
that what I'm saying is the following
yeah
the reason I'm saying this and we need
to be brutally honest here and the
reason I'm saying this you know why
because sisters are under the impression
that there is a man out there that is um
not polygamous I believe
it's true not every man
let me tell you something if they bought
a lie detector test right now the second
no no you know why
and they said the following questions do
you love your wife yes boss would you
die for her yes pause if your wife is
okay would you get a second wife yes
pass there is not a conflict between a
man loving his wife
and a man wanting to be polygamous I
agree and this is very important if
we're going to and I'm not saying I look
I hear you out here but what I'm saying
is
listen let's party okay let's pass it
because we're here to make myself
every man would want to yes
is
Sue I'm the reason why I started the
show and I called it bitter Truth for a
reason yeah is because at the end of my
wife is here she's a co-producer okay if
I went to my wife and said if I got
married again she would say Oh My Dead
Body I don't want it I understand that
and any woman that says she's not she's
okay with it I'll say I'm so sorry
you're not because the best of the women
who are believers smashed plates
literally smashed plates yeah now the
point is the following though
the reason you're saying that sister is
why because we as men we are and the
studies that show this we are created in
a way of procreative for example
if for example there was four men left
on Earth yeah
and that was it yeah they can start a
new generation those four men they can
forgive me just for educational purposes
yeah they can impregnate thousands of
women
that's that's within our nature but if a
woman there was four women left on this
planet yeah they're finished because
you're giving birth nine months you're
out the game so the point I'm saying
when it comes to the evolution
um and a few other factors the point I'm
trying to say is the following English
like like you know like when it comes to
survival things that you have to
procreate yeah okay
okay every man is polygamist by nature
in the context where
because you guys are monogamous by
nature meaning you are you just want
your husband and you're happy with your
husband we are not created like that and
anyone that says they are vice versa
it's and this is the reason why we
started the show get to know us better
understand us men this is in our blood
okay now coming back
I know what you mean no what I mean is
that in our nation this person is our
nature yes can you reframe the question
okay I'm so sorry so can you read one
second guys one second guys from there
please you let my wife know and then for
me and then I'll come to you guys
because can you reframe the question to
the brothers and say that if your wife
agreed and she's happy would you like to
look I did the polygamous part I get the
whole one thing to have more intimacy
with more than one woman yeah but if you
can ask the question
um more accurately that take on another
wife and all the responsibilities that
come with another wife how many men will
agree to that good you know what and
that's a good point and that's I'll tell
you with my husband he's very clear in
that yeah that you know the headache and
the stress not that I give him headache
but just he's so content in our
relationship okay he wouldn't see
himself you know engaged in another that
because okay okay
this is the reason why the topic is
secret second wives is the question that
needs to ask is that why are men even
choosing to make it secret and the whole
reason is because if your husband should
have come to you and say
hmm I I want to get married again and I
want to do it properly yeah now I see to
the sisters if you don't want your
husband to get a second wife you tell
him that if he's going to get a second
wife he has to do it properly meaning
which is what and let me tell you
something if you don't want your husband
to get second wife implement this yeah
you tell him you're going to marry her
you're gonna do willima for her you're
going to get her mother you're going to
get all of this stuff you know what
you're saying he'll say bro that's long
absolutely but if there are men out
there who can do that the question I
want to ask you guys is what is the
right way so men don't go behind their
wife's back why are they keeping a
secret because they are scared of the
consequences not seeing their kids being
kicked out being black these are major
sins by the way not showing your kids I
know brothers who have been divorced and
not seeing their kids because they
wanted to get second wife this is
Judgment are you mad something he did
Halal understand this emotional you're
upset you are stopping them from seeing
these kids you are now going to the law
bro we had Brothers here we had fathers
here accused of pedophilia with their
kids because of a bitter wife asking a
simple question yeah I think that's bill
isma here you guys will never win it we
would definitely
where a husband cannot marry a second
one like if he agrees and signs on the
day of the Nikka that he cannot he
cannot then go and get a secret but if
somebody doesn't believe that it's
buttered he doesn't he doesn't even
apology yeah and and also and also yes
yes yes yes I'm gonna give it to you but
after he after him I want to ask you
guys a question please can you tell us
the correct way of going about it so
it's not secret but this is what she
said is there's truth in what she said
um
it's actually mentioned in all the books
of the uh
um
so this is what you're saying is
legitimate in fact if someone puts in
the in the contract maybe I shouldn't
give an audience
actually don't agree with this and the
reason why is they bring that there's a
Hadith that says
that any condition that is not in the
book of Allah then it's nullified so
they say that this is a incorrect so the
hand of his own acceptance don't accept
this and the Americans don't accept this
so if the woman is humbly for example
she she puts this agreement and he's not
this thing
no but he's not listening he doesn't
it's all about what he believes in if he
doesn't believe in it it might not be
voracious however I would put to this I
would add to it the prophet sallam did
say Muslim to him Muslims are upon their
condition which is
you know all you who believe uh fulfill
the contracts yes so if a man does sign
something like that I would personally
believe this obligation for him to
having said that once again it goes back
to the mother who's following right so
if he's not following that particular
school of thought if she is if he isn't
that's something else so that's just uh
I think there's a good point okay so
before we slide away because I feel like
the first question that was asked about
a secret uh is it okay to have a secret
life I wanted I would love to go back
there I mean I think
I I haven't personally looked into it so
I'll take your word so I don't know that
might be a different opinion I don't
know I take what hijab said about like
that it's like agreed upon that you you
shouldn't um that's okay to do a secret
but I would love to speak about the
implications that it has a bit more
because it's um something I feel like
um um that we didn't really discuss
because okay because the implication
here is that
the seek like okay obviously nothing is
really secret again you can't have a
secret life per se because
yeah it's uh marriage in Islam the way
it's the um it's constructed yeah but
let's not sugarcoat it it's a secret
from the first way
yes this is the whole thing that's
finished because because
I'm trying to take it elsewhere I'm
trying to go deep I want to go deep I
want to go deep so what I'm trying to
say is that
um Islam in a way that Islam has um
constructed marriages marriage is like a
communal thing so there's always other
people involved
um but uh it would be a secret to the
person that matters the most which is
the wife right and I don't think that uh
that causes cohesion uh in the long term
in a in a society imagine if we were to
live in a society where there's a
considerable amount of man who do this
and there's so many implications that
come out of it the children out of those
marriages do they do they know that
they're siblings thank you so glad
you've mentioned so all these problems
yes true but why let me just imagine I'm
just going to finish I'm just gonna I'm
just going to finish why is the man
Keeping a Secret yeah and I'm gonna get
there and I'm with you on that one I'm
just saying that
for those brothers who do these things
you just always you must understand that
the the pain and uh the misery that
could be a byproduct of this thing is is
tremendous and and therefore I wouldn't
like I said
there's a very important point you
mentioned the kids that's that's an
important Point inheritance is another
important Point these are two things you
can't read Because actually the Messiah
thing you cannot actually
on inheritance
you cannot forego that right as a woman
yes you know you're a lot of people go
rights you're not allowed to go your
inheritance yeah so it poses an issue
here so the guy has to kind of put her
in the inheritance or whatever that's
one issue the other issue is like we
said the children if there's children
from both wives and they're in the same
proximity and there is some level of
possibility that they could call mingle
then that could be completely Haram for
them for that to happen because now the
implications isn't incest and all that
kind of stuff exactly so this is this is
one thing but having said this you know
and I agree with you he said this is
what we're talking about is an
exceptional circumstance that Sharia
doesn't want this yeah it's clear that
the Sharia wants people to know about
marriages it's clear that Sharia wants
there to be a transparency in the
equation that everyone has given it's
clear that the Sharia doesn't want this
yard it's clear that this is not these
are the exceptional circumstances so we
shouldn't make it the the default having
said that why we're living in an age now
where frankly
the woman has the state backing
like for instance if a woman if the
woman goes and says that a man has raped
me or that she he has molested the child
or he's been domestic he can there's a
chance that he can never see the
children again like for example the gov
website I just I was reading recently
just now like two days ago
um they're now expanding the definition
of abuse they said abuse I can send this
to you that abuse includes
um in controlling Behavior now
controlling Behavior what does that is
so vague that it can it actually slides
into some of the traditionist discourse
if you think about it controlling
Behavior setting is setting the dog.gov
website that it is on par with physical
violence and if a man does it he can be
on the sexual
um uh register sorry I was on a
documentary for the BBC and it's called
is this coercive control and when when
we speak of coercing control the reason
why it can be equated to physical
violence is because of the amount of
damage that can happen coercive control
although it doesn't seem
um like dangerous I know what you're
saying of course a mirror for my
original document it used two keywords
in in self like it was self-contained
different sentences coercion was one
word and control was another word what
you're doing now is using both questions
no but they are one thing so coercive
control is one because it is one it is
no no the reason they're not the same
because in the dictionary you'll see
coercion means to force someone to do
something control is not necessarily it
can have a wider meaning right so what
I'm saying is if you controlling
Behavior you could say my mom had
controlling behavior of me she was
controlling you could you cannot say
that she had coercive behavior that
means that she forced to do something
what I'm saying is that we're not
talking about forcing someone to do
something here like putting them in a
house and locking them we're talking
about a situation where someone is
telling someone else what to do which
you can see that leads into tar and
obedience and that kind of thing which
that could be seen as controlling so
what I'm saying is that if consider that
consider the things that demands
disposal as a Muslim man he's got time
okay
obedience these are the things that man
has he's got talak or she can do fast
but he can do it quicker even she can do
physical right and then he's got the
fine Financial thing where he can reduce
according to Ultima there uh I'm not
sure all of them definitely method he
can if she's being bad she could take
money away from her
I'm not sure if you know this if she's
natural now if you do one and two this
can be seen in this country as abuse so
if she if she has evidence of that and
she's got the stake back in if he tries
to impose his masculinity or his Islamic
uh you know abilities on her then she
can respond in a malicious manner which
is why I would say that if a woman shows
her claws in that way where now she's
doing what he's what he's allowed to do
in Islam and she's now giving him
blackmailing threatening and stuff like
that in a situation like this I would
actually recommend for certain men where
he feels like if she knew she blackmails
him if you get divorced to me another
man will raise your children or let's
say let me just say yeah for example if
if you get divorced to get if if this
happens you'll never see your children
again the moment you see a woman
speaking like that this is an option of
secret second whatever you want to call
it I think it becomes a very religious
option but and and are meant to blame to
go down that route when they have wives
who are going to make their life help
so just to get back to that point I
think it's fine but there's a there's a
there's a a term in Islam
where somebody is now abusing that and
it says I'm sure there's a Hadith it
says where you shouldn't do that to your
wife for a prolonged time and it was
somebody
so uh insulting or taking away their
rights and things like that if somebody
is abusing that then okay that's one
case but of course there are women out
here who do abuse the the state backing
in in regards to the children which I'm
completely in disagreeance with okay
um sometimes before you continue I don't
think what you said is correct but uh
which means don't hit don't humiliate
the face you know there's a there's a
Hadith on that but so just we need to be
clear
okay sorry can I make the point so for
me I agree going down that route okay
hiding it from their wives because we
don't want this to be secret I'll be
honest with no man wants to keep it
secret no man wants to go do anything
behind his wife's but so the pin the
point is this if we are created in this
manner you guys are created with certain
hormones yes for example because we're
learning here yes the period you have
your menopause you become pregnant Etc
there are so many factors men don't
blame women and say oh you know why in
your periods why aren't menopauseful
yeah and when it comes to intimacy a lot
of men actually feel deprived their
their Partners just they're not as
bothered and the thing is here that now
we as men are men are blamed no no we as
men are blamed for a hormone that we are
created reactive to hormone you know the
hormone no problem we can no intimacy
for a week no problem menopause
pregnancy is so good when a man has
these hormones number one you are not
allowed to have it number two if you
were to go to act upon it I'm going to
make your life hell so I'm asking a
simple question what do what does a man
should do tell me the men want to know
the correct way of going about this
without making it secret second wife
because to me from my point of view it
seems like none of the men's one none of
the men want to make it secret but the
pressure outside pressures from our
wives and God knows what other elements
is causing men to be like you know what
I have to go the secret way for me I
agree polygamy is permissible a man
doesn't need to you know I can't go away
from Islam he doesn't need to tell me
okay but
aside from El Islam I think my Integrity
my dignity my
you know who I am as a person I would
think it's so disrespectful for my
husband to go and marry somebody else
secretly without giving me the knowledge
without no okay wait
before openly If he if we're talking
about secret second wife if my husband
has gone behind my back that to me is
cheating even if it is islamically
correct however wait hold on if he was
to come to me prior to you know prior to
him doing this and having that
conversation with me which we've already
openly discussed this
I want a second wife genuinely we would
have a conversation sorry I'm not
somebody who's not understanding however
at least he gave me an option first and
he's given me a ride in a way so I can
make an informed decision for myself
let's go back to what you said before
aside Islam dignity respects are with
respect to that aside the slam or beside
that you don't have any of those things
anyway dignity or respect I know I agree
so it's just this idea of aside Islam
we're Muslims there is not Satan Islam
in this discussion if I was speaking to
an atheist as I do we can bring in
liberalism and feminism I'm speaking to
a Muslim so there is no aside Islam here
that's the first thing okay but you said
lying is not okay but it is okay for for
husbands if he's lying to me every night
he speaks so let me just come back to
the second point in English you said
it's cheating
cheating is a word that's a construct in
English language which means infidelity
usually for the most part right Fidelity
for us it means someone has done
something which is
Major scene major scenes of Islam we
cannot equate something which is mobash
which is that Sharia has not even put a
sin on it with something which is
kabiram and Quebec which means now
you're going back to the True Religion
which I'm now expected as a Muslim man
to follow it's not the religion of Islam
it's the religion of woman's feelings
I'm not going to follow that religion
with respect to you I'm not going to do
uh frustration to the collective
hormonal and emotional status of men or
women or children or anybody else I'm
not going to do this so I'm saying now
we'll go back to the book and the Sunnah
the question is
what exactly are we objecting to I'm
saying that at the end of the day
everyone here has agreed
that this is not what Sharia wants it's
not the best case scenario it's not the
default situation
in fact what Ali said at the end there
was a very good point because let's say
for example a woman withholds from the
man sexually
it's one of the major sins of Islam one
of the heavy sins Lana is born it's not
like candy the Angels the Angels if the
woman withholds from the man that the
angels will continue cursing them until
he wakes up now if a woman is doing this
to a man
and you know this is my advice and this
is controversial my advice to the
brother is to get married again now I'm
saying that he can either do it secretly
without her knowledge or not secretly if
he knows that she would withhold the
kids from him use the state then do it
without knowledge but I believe that's a
form of abuse when a woman is
withholding just because she wants them
to say something the sister I've come
across so many women that you know
because we've we're we're from in
Pakistan the men come in here from
because they when they get married over
there they bring the men here and they
abuse him abuse him bad you know I mean
they don't let him to do anything they
work they take the money off them you
know they give them nothing you know
what I mean so the thing is what they're
do they have a secret marriage but the
way their women look at it they're
rather the man she thank you then to get
married you know what I mean so the
thing is they say oh commits you know
about be with your wife you know what I
mean and this is the time we live in
tonight you know what I mean I agree
some women have that mentality no not
some woman sister listen I believe some
women have that mentality but can we go
sister the solution is men need to stop
being cowards and speak to the wife
yeah if your husband came to assist you
on your husband and preserve your
marriage and it protects you guys you're
seeing if he's man enough if your
husband came to you man enough and said
to you he wants a second wife at least
then it's not secretary
again it's again it's again a bit
selfish because you're like I just want
to know about it okay you know about it
are you gonna what are you gonna do are
you gonna say to me you can thank you
your face
[Laughter]
we need to do like when you're a married
couple every problem you have
you discuss it so this is again for us
as women it's a problem and for him it's
a problem so if we sit down and we talk
about it and I take my selfish needs out
of it I.E me wanting him all to myself I
need to understand that there's more
like that's how Allah has made them and
Allah has opened up up to four wives for
them so I need to sit down and I need to
really think about how this is going to
affect him it could lead him into doing
Zilla it could lead him to do Haram
stuff and I really need to understand do
I want that for my husband again we need
to be in a relationship where we're both
empathetic towards each other if we
expect our husbands to understand oh I'm
really moody because I'm on my oh you
know I'm pregnant so I'm feeling so if
we want them to understand us why is it
us as women can't return the favor and
understand them thank you and we're
going to go to Sister Soulshine she
wants to ask a question can we get the
cameras to Sister sword inshallah
is one of the sisters who have an
amazing contribution to our podcast
um I disagree with some stuff she says
but I still invited to the show
one of the things that no one is
mentioning is the fact that
alhamdulillah make the point that when
obviously husbands are being denied this
hack and women are starting to threaten
with the kids and that and they are very
maybe in a talking situation we get that
like the brother Muhammad says
um it's allowed but no one is talking
with the fact that brothers are using
to treat wives and abusing those
situations because sometimes they are
cowards sometimes they don't want to
travel they don't want the voice you
annoy them rather than going convincing
them being the man making sure they have
the right protector provider showing
that what they are able to take care of
two families they will rather let's just
be honest okay no rent and grab a second
wife
just a quick thing yeah
um but I'm gonna you know you know who
I'm gonna blame in this very instance
I'm gonna blame the sisters because
I'm so sorry not everybody here that
there was a statement that was made I
saw on Instagram it said when a woman is
divorced she's not divorced she's
divorced by her husband not divorced by
the ummah and when I say the sister was
like yeah it's so true and I was like
yes sister you know you would you share
your husband oh what happened your face
you start crying what happened she's not
divorced by the woman are you not a part
of the ummah so the question is this
sisters are so sabotaging the other
sisters feminist sisters who love their
sisters who will die for their sisters
will take a bullet for their sisters but
will not share their husbands for their
sisters so the point is this you know
let me be real yeah if you love your if
you've got a good husband by the way I'm
not talking about these guys who don't
pray jahil clowns yeah who don't pray
who oppress their wives a good man who
practices who fears Allah he's good to
his wife takes care of his wife he comes
and he says I want a second wife all
hell breaks news and then we blame this
man yeah but why are you keeping it
secret what else should he do don't can
I make a point sorry just on that before
I lose it so as Muslim men we understand
that the woman has yeah we know that the
best of us women broke plates like you
mentioned
yes but we understand that well it
wasn't it wasn't awesome thing no but we
we understand that this was this is a
painful thing and Men you guys
understand it more that it may hurt the
wife okay so you know that the reaction
is always going to be tough so this is
why we say it's cowardice and cowardly
sorry why do we need to bring our names
into it because it is it's cowardly when
a man doesn't go to his wife to tell her
because he's afraid of that reaction
he's just afraid of the reaction
this one
where is
Allah is telling us what the prophet
yeah
the prophet saws this is the Quran
you're reading it you're going to read
it in Ramadan
[Music]
which means he hid information from part
of his wives and told other parts of his
wives now he told even he went to those
wives that he hid the information he
said do not tell these otherwise
you see what's happening here now let me
let me make it even more controversial
for you some yeah some people in tafsir
yeah there's two ways what what is this
talking about you might know the honey
story yeah the honey story when
they conspired and stuff this is the
most famous opinion opinion but there's
another opinion which is that actually
the person
he took her to the bed of hafsa and he
had intercourse with her on her night in
her house and then this is what the
prophet sallam told her don't tell the
other ones
but in that case we're saying that to
hide information from some of the wives
is not countless if you if you accuse
this you if you want to use this word
cowardice to describe hiding information
from some of the wives then you'll be
implicating number one no yes
I'm just saying this is the this is the
implication I say that this is the bait
that a stupid man will take
his wife is already threatening him
blackmailing him and do this kind of
things she he knows that the state has
got his back uh her backing in those
situations where you can see her claws
on her malice
and stuff like that I would say to the
brothers that want to do polygamy and
not let the first wife do never fall for
that bait ever
but
there is there is there is there is a
hecma in not telling your spouse
something sometimes I understand that I
understand the logic because I'm a
logical thing said that I'm not saying
that this is the rule I'm still telling
you this is the exception but it's the
exception for whom for because we're
living in an age where there is a
pandemic now of women using their
children weaponizing them against their
husbands saying you can never see your
children again you will never be able to
see them again and it happens we've seen
them some of them commit suicide some of
them want them on the show one of them
so many of them it's becoming too much
so I'm saying that instead of doing
domestic violence instead of doing
things which will get you a record in
this country ruining your life doing it
do this this for me I believe that this
is a better option yeah than going into
all these things which the woman's gonna
put you in the prison because she has so
much uh she's she that particular woman
which in my opinion is the minority of
women majority of Muslim women thank you
I believe I believe it's minority of
women if it's five percent of them or 10
I don't know how many of them yeah but
they're willing to go down there it's
the minority of women minority of
minority of women but for those women
this should apply well at least it's an
option for the man I
I wouldn't say it's majority of women I
wouldn't say it's minor to a woman it's
just a thing of the moment you come to
your wife and say I want a second wife
then you will realize if that's minority
is a majority
um yeah I'm gonna go to Sister SWAT just
a few disclaimers here
um when we're talking about this topic
some people come and say to me but why
are you so obsessed people come to me
and go back
okay even my wife says why are you so
obvious with it yeah the reason I say is
my witness yeah Okay the reason I say is
bro I hear stories this is breaking the
family unit there are men that you said
bro and I'll call them cows who would
rather make their wife happy at the
displeasure of Allah yeah a cow with the
biggest cow would ever that would go and
commit Zina adultery at the cost of my
wife you are the biggest simp ever with
a capital S yeah yeah especially because
you have the option to marry exactly and
the thing is you fear your wife so much
so the reason I'm talking about this is
because I see family units breaking down
this is the reason why I'm doing this
show yeah yes the money might be like
yeah because you're a man you want
wallahi the reason I do is because I see
the breakdown of the family family unit
and why because men like I was the
assistant said your wife may Allah bless
her why would but what the man really
want that you need to understand the
system if we understand each other
better our biology the way we think
psychology marriages will improve
scissors and just following off what you
said I think that's the very a good
point that you just made us
understanding each other's biology and
when so you know you were saying about
he's a coward for
um coming at you and saying that he
wants a second wife I don't know I said
he's a coward if he doesn't come at you
yeah as as a wife I think that is very
powerful this is the thing this is the
The Logical thinking in a man's in in a
man's head he's weighing up the pros and
cons he knows you as his wife he knows
how you are going to react to that based
on other conversations you had so I I
don't think it's cowardice for him to
say actually it's not worth me having
this headache it's not worth me blowing
up my family and for men it's a lot
worse you know if you guys were to get
divorced and you know I'm not saying it
for you you know but if a man or woman
were to to get divorced it's more the
man that has to
um that that the courts come heavily
down
and and the reason why he's doing it is
because he doesn't feel confident in us
as women to be able to have a logical
conversation we're very emotional so
instantly we his second wife and me
included our jealousy goes straight
through the roof we don't want to hear
anything else you've got to say whereas
he's sitting there with a logical mind
so then you've got two illogical Minds
if you like because I'm emotional and
he's just like look it's it's from A to
B and I'm going you know well what about
CDE and you know going around the
circles and that's where the problem
comes so he's thinking rather than
dealing with this headache let me just
go do what I want to do and then that's
where we have to take accountability as
women that we have to be accountable for
our husbands having to lie to us because
we can't have that logical conversation
so it should be a case
I feel like
yes your husband has his his needs and
his wants and his desires and you might
not be fulfilling that but I would
expect my husband to put my children
before all of that personally
well my business okay we're going to go
to my dear sister what you said may
Allah
fans are coming but look at what look
imagine imagine a man imagine your
husband coming and saying that you have
a hormonal need whatever it may be and
he's like you need to put me the kids
above and you're like well I can't help
it and you're like no but if you have so
what I'm saying is just so you can
understand is better better my dear
sister yeah is that if he said that well
why the feminist will be in his house
with stones rocket throwing rocks yeah
so the thing is and now we're coming
from 100 I hear you out but we are
created in a way where we are being
attacked with something that is in our
body that we cannot help but okay then
sister Ira wants to ask a question
yeah I I definitely got one and a half
minutes gone I think definitely as women
Muslim women in living in the west we
need to take that ownership on like um
sister then said that if your husband is
worried to speak to you then you know
over this matter then number one there's
you know something quite deep between
your relationship where if something
deeply disturbs you as a spouse you
should be able to seek counsel in your
husband and vice versa now if you've
overreacted in other things uh you know
it could be something you've met his I
don't know his eyes gazed away you know
momentarily and you pick that up and you
threw a big you know a fuss about it
there's no way he's going to feel
comfortable enough to come and speak to
you about that so I definitely think as
women we need to take that
responsibility on that if our husband
um they're not they don't feel
comfortable enough to talk to us then
it's something about our approach and
how we've handled
um you know um situations or scenarios
around that case I think another thing
um really really important is if if a
system my advice would be to all sisters
that if you find yourself in a position
where your husband has expressed 30
seconds that he um he wants to get
married again and you know not
necessarily seeking your permission but
more of an in um informed you know
informing you that it's something you
have to
you know reflect on yourself and prepare
yourself exactly and reflect on yourself
all these years I have enjoyed a blessed
marriage and that you know and
one-to-one with my husband but now my
reality is going to be different I'm
going to be tested on my emotions on my
Jealousy on my connections with Allah on
how I react to scenarios so I say
personal Journey that the woman needs to
consciously Embark in and feel like well
this is a test to see how Allah is
testing her to see how she responds yes
you know if she decides to do the
opposite which is you know
um you know throw the divorce card or
throw this card then ultimately she is
falling into the act of Disobedience
but look how productive it is we're
trying to understand each other we're
trying to learn no one's playing me no
one knows we're just trying to
understand each other better don't so um
as a hearing the sisters what they said
right now it's quite a contrast because
at the beginning they're like Over My
Dead Body so in I still stand yeah
I feel like I'm less than the only one
who's like do not even think about it
I'm just saying in response
so in responsible because there was a
lot of like a very long monologue that
was given here and I'm sure the husbands
are watching this so in a way you give
an ammunition to your husbands because
they're here in Europe but what I'm
trying to say I totally agree with what
this is the Same by the way um so like
there's an attempt right now sort of
like
um there's this guy called Dustin uh
that's this guy the YouTuber and uh he's
known to be like a debate or whatever
and like there is like an attempt right
now like in the Western World to like
normalize open relationships
we're like so for those who don't know
what that is it's like where female and
the husband both uh
um in agreement to have sexual
relationships outside their marriages so
there's an attempt to normalize this and
you see that a lot of like even the
non-muslims are like not down with that
um what I'm trying to say is that I
think if you look at places like Yemen I
saw this video as funny that's this guy
he's on a compound yeah and there's this
white guy next to him and he goes like
how many eyes do you have he was like I
don't know he had lose of women
83. there is an opinion that says you
can have nine wives and this is the
opinion but yeah let's go let's go to it
in response you look very strong opinion
I'm not saying it's the right one I
believe in the fall but yeah I believe
in foreign
foreign
isn't it interesting that I in the Quran
starts with marrying twos yeah threes
and fours and the scholars say that the
fact that Allah started with two not one
because it says Marion choose threes and
fours if you can't be just marry one
meaning the default position is every
man should have two wives and when he's
like nah this is too much for me then
have another wife but one wife yeah so
the guy responds and laughs at him
because like how many wives do you have
because like I have one and you start
laughing please come to my generator
guys he's on the compound and his wives
are all seeing this so what I'm trying
to say is I think it's a cultural thing
because and I said this before last time
in African-American Community amongst
the Muslims it seems to be that polygyny
it's more accepted and this is something
to discuss and this is something it's a
reality because of the um uh the the
equation in terms of the amount of man
being in prison and the amount of man
the ratio between men amount of men who
are homosexuals also in Atlanta and
places like that so the female over
there are
accustomed more to reality and therefore
they are more happy to share husbands
and I think so it's not necessary to do
if you know we like to see a lot the
nature of the female the nature like
human can adapt in it like we can adapt
there are always going to be certain
things about about us that are hardwired
you're right but like we can adapt like
we can have a society what the system
was saying was husbands and wives can
have conversations about this myself and
my wife we had these discussions before
and you know what because my wife was
she always gave me the um
so the feeling that I could be open with
her I told her at one point that look
babe that's the sister
that's possibly a sister this is early
on it yeah I did certain things wrong
yeah yeah Francis sorry babes but
I did tell her yeah I did tell her right
yeah it's an honorable man who's done in
an honorable way come on on the only
reason God told her was because she gave
me the feeling that I could talk to her
about it I mean but then I but yeah okay
okay
hurry Ally because of you I actually had
this conversation check this out check
this out check this out so sister Amira
had this conversation with her husband
uh because of me how did it go so can we
can we zoom in please it's a very open
person yeah
um and for me my Integrity matters the
most because at the end of the day if we
based our relationship on trust and
honesty and just you know like we're
friends you know we're friends before
husband or wife I would feel so hurt if
my husband couldn't talk to me and go
and marry somebody else behind my back
and then now it's leaking into lying to
me on a day-to-day basis going to meet
some next chick I don't even know did he
did he did she test because less less
faces a lot of men marry women without
even getting certain dresses and then if
he brings me some disease back then it
will be his janaza for real literally
because so what did you have okay okay
bless you and by the way it's just a
mirror
um just because there's some um people
um she's not wearing a hijab properly
she actually doesn't wear hijab and
she's trying to so for those people some
jazz yeah she's actually come to the
show and wears it and sold this our uh
the thing to see are for those people
who are sick and talking about this
nonsense just to give a disclaimer
please control your tongues so anyways
you had a discussion with your husband
yes I want to know what did he say well
we I I literally had to open a
discussion and maybe if he you know
he'll come on one day definitely so I
need to meet him
um and I just said you know would you
want to get a second wife like and for
him he said no like I said no he said no
please I beg you bring him here
you have to bear in mind I am five wives
in one night sorry sister you know I'm
even nine wives That's this point
to do I want you to bring your husband
here
sister I'm telling you bring your
husband here I'm telling you give me
three and a half minutes but I ended up
coming I ended up saying to him like
look if you did ever change your mind
and for whatever reason he's already
decided for whatever reason you wanted
to actually get married again yeah have
that discussion with me openly because
although it might hurt me although it
might be something that I'm not in favor
of
I would see why I would understand and
obviously go back to the dean and
understand that we're going to assist at
once I'm gonna come may Allah bless you
and by the way guys Jokes Aside here
this is a serious matter yeah the
prophet peace be upon him said that a
man who has two wives and he favors one
over the other will come on the day of
judgment lean in his body we'll be
leaning on one side we joke around here
this and there but it's not a joking
matter it's a serious matter involves
another woman invoice her emotions
there's so many factors I'm not here to
say Pro against or just one all I want
to do in the show is so we understand
just understand us well life just
understand us the way we understand you
that's always I'm not saying to anybody
go and get married again Etc because
there's consequences like you said even
hijab he said he doesn't recommend it
because it can be detrimental no man who
does this by the way to the sisters
wakes up and says I'm going to ruin my
wife's life right now and make her
suffer no man does that well he believe
us we are created in a way where
sometimes it can be Peak and it should
be done in the correct way that's why
Allah sent these protocols in place
because men like to do it in a way
without responsibilities let me get what
I want no no no no no brother that's why
I tell the sisters if he's going to do
it you tell him you marry that woman you
give a Maher you do all of that stuff
you know what he's going to say no I
ain't got time for that next one this is
the IRA and then we're gonna come to the
brothers and we're gonna wrap up we need
to wrap up Sister IRA
foreign
[Applause]
adjustments especially from the women's
side so why can you not
approach this desire
secondly what I wanted to say was
um
now that that love is going to be split
50 50. let's just say there's two wives
in the scenario
right he's out here investing 100 of
herself mentally emotionally physically
at home
teacher but she's only getting 50
percent
you know because he's only going to be
spending half the time with her whether
that is physically or whether that is
emotional quality promise me not just
that but if a woman is acting now then
um then acting more psychotic about why
but
something to say like yeah
who has a past because you know yeah
it's not the same thing I've always got
the past
much like that I would imagine a woman
to find it very difficult
but her man will now have this woman and
it's not just
yeah they're having in the past but
mother but sister it's not it's not
about us though
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
one second
wait wait let me it's almost like that
okay please yes you're right it's not
about us but it is to some degree it is
about me it's not 100 about me I am just
as much in the relationship as he is you
can't take me out of the equation not
going to take out my emotions my
well-being and the children well-being
because I'm not okay in my mind
[Music]
on you to work on as a woman
to manage your own emotions and do and
that's what I was saying earlier on when
I said try and no that's what I was
saying to everyone I said we need to try
and understand member they they
understand us very well they know when
we're not feeling great when there's
certain things going on but when they're
coming to us with an issue that is very
very sensitive rather than saying okay
let me sit down and see how I can help
my husband how I can nobody knows
let me finish let me finish let me
finish let me finish let me finish yeah
hang on so this this is about us trying
to help them with their this is
something that Allah has ingrained into
them it's they can't help it it's like
being born with one hand they can't help
it
exactly so then we need to work together
look I'm not I'm the same I'm going to
say to you that I would not want my
husband to have us guys
so you're causing oppression
guys hello sorry this please
guys guys one second please one second
there's a few things that was the touch
the point I want to come to we're gonna
we're gonna wrap up inshallah okay
um yes so what I'm saying is in a
nutshell is that the man feels less
loved when the woman spends more time
with his kids he's given 50 of the love
and this this is that show that men feel
deprived yeah now when it comes to
desire all you do is you're equating
Desire with using your mind is marriage
but yours is just desire it's like me
belittling what you're going through
what if I came and said for example that
you're going through menopause and your
period And when you're pregnant as well
when the woman's pregnant is sorry just
we've been learning here it's hard to
have intimacy okay so can the man come
and say hold on a second I am being
deprived and there are studies that show
a man's sexual drive there is no
comparison so this is the reason why we
say but biologically when I had a
discussion with a toxic feminist girl
yeah
you guys are vulnerable in a altercation
when it comes to a a manual biologically
weaker that is your most vulnerable
state you're in you require a man to be
there to protect you and man's most
vulnerable state is when it comes to
intimacy and when a man is deprived of
that you are also saying on top of that
you are not allowed to get married again
you have to shut up and um go through
whatever I'm going through and put up
with it so it's unfair just on the
points he said he wanted guidance and
clarification
um but it did seem a bit like a polemic
but I would say that the first and
second points that you made anyway
had assumptions of it of a liberal and
feministic kind undoubtedly the first
one was you were talking about
well these are the desires of men and
this is who says that we are living our
lives on the hedonistic principle who
says that we are living our lives that
the pain and pleasure threshold is what
we we base morality on this is not what
we despite the fact that sometimes we
can feel bad about something that could
be good for you the Quran says that very
clearly I mean it's we don't believe
that just because something can feel bad
to an individual man woman or child but
that thing becomes bad itself so this
idea remember Islam has a communitarian
ethic at the end of the day it's not
about what's good for the individual
actors it's about what's good for the
collective number one number two is not
just that it's about what's good that
Allah wants us to worship him for
example military Warfare
that military Warfare has been
prescribed upon you and something
disliked by you
know you could hate something it's good
for you and you could love something
that's bad for you so the first the
premise of the first question is
completely falsified in fact probably
it's almost as if I'm speaking to with
respect I'm not Muslim wouldn't matter
because I'll say to them if I'll speak
to them how do you prove your premise
that in fact the egoistic
individualistic liberal hedonistic
principle that you have is actually a
true one in the first place to base
morality that's the first thing the
second thing is when you said that well
she's putting in this much in the
relationship and he's putting in this
much you've assumed equality is
undoubtedly you've assumed equality and
once again that's feminism second with
feminism you've imported that into the
religious discourse and then challenged
us with it remember we're not we're not
we don't agree with feminism I don't
believe that equality and value equals
identicality of roles I believe that the
equality of value between men and women
but the roles are different
so even if the man puts in ten percent
five percent one percent into a
relationship and she puts on 100 that
wouldn't indicate to me there's
Injustice going on disparity or inequity
so for me this is not the way that the
situation is being dealt with so all of
in short therefore I would say that all
of your questions seem to have an import
of a post-enlightenment liberal Colonial
white mankind which we don't need to
have when we're having these discussions
between Muslims in fact if we're this
you can you can see the discussion so
far has been from at least a big section
of today's has been Quran Sunnah when we
talk about Quran Scholars
about 50 of this hundred percent this
feelings this we're not following the
religion of feelings and I said before
I'm not going to prostrate or bow down
to anyone's feelings here so in some
therefore I think if we want to
challenge a position as Muslim people we
need to challenge the Muslim people with
Islam not with something imported from
outside or presuppositions which have a
a different kind of backdrop so that's
what I'll say to you it's very important
that we get that right may Allah bless
you hijab and also just to bear in mind
we're not seeing that as and we're going
to come since Ira because I finished the
two more points you're going to make it
we're going to probably wrap up with
what she says uh but just to touch up on
the thing we're just trying to say we're
not we're not saying that we don't care
about you emotions Etc we're just saying
that the Quran comes first and also for
example um says the iron also just to
touch upon you is that if you think
about it as men
um when a thief breaks the house
um we have to go down and we might not
return back when a war happens like it's
happened in Ukraine these trans women
are told shut up you're a man now come
and join the war yeah
um so when it comes to that can you
imagine we have to go and I might be
coming home just imagine as a man that
we have for our wives bro imagine you're
going to war and your you know you might
get well killed you're not coming back
your wife is getting married to another
man yeah we don't come and say well hold
on a second buff why do you go everyday
buff Curry human something delicious
dishes here you go to what and I'll cook
no what would what would my wife say who
say shut up you are the man yeah you
have to go we as men don't miss the good
point we as men don't complain we are
ready to put our neck on the line for
our family our Dean and go and we don't
talk about emotions that go well hold on
a second we fight that someone's going
to marry you you're going to be with
someone else but why is it that when as
men we talk about our concerns and what
we go through and our hormones we are
shun be quiet and you're hurting me but
vice versa it's not the same can I just
say sorry this is a western point of
view because
like so in terms of polygamy yeah it is
a western point of view in Africa
Senegal Ivory Coast Nigeria this is more
normalized so us from a western gaze it
is more of a oh you know because we have
been brought up in a monogamous type of
mindset Romney and Juliet however most
Scholars do not recommend from new
Julian stations for men to have secret
wives most Scholars do say just tell the
wife or make it known because of XYZ
that's all I want to exactly you said
you didn't finish your phone I don't
want to cut you off context
last point
I knew there was a problem there was a
plot twist
yes
should be refuted when we go home what
do you have to say about that say that
again
just text me come back to me women do
Jihad every time they give birth women
do Jihad every time they wear hijab in
the western world she has every day
right for women
it's a reputation to my wife can we get
the cameras crossed please
I'll be fasting with my new wife
okay now okay look guys inside here
yes yes
if you are lying hiding and asking the
second one how can you accept me okay I
just want to know the fact okay okay
good I think we discussed enough no
woman even if she knows that origin and
I can tell you yeah because I know
people that have said that yeah because
they've put themselves already in a
really bad situation yeah
feelings for the person yeah very often
they have put themselves in a situation
that now makes the marriage an
obligation okay yes
sister soul have mercy on us please
only one day a week it's fine as long as
I have you in my life but it will never
last and we all know that because every
woman will want to have what the other
one has okay okay
and and and only that not only that we
talked about this in the other episode
of polygamy we discussed this so today's
topic is more about secret seven what
polygamy we discussed this it's going to
come out
yes yes maybe we can have another
discussion on its own because it's a
broad topic and talking about how he's
standing up
I I I I I I understand what I'm saying
is
time is running now Sister time is
running out look we're nearly two hours
yeah
I know sister but it's time is run now
part two to be continued yeah uh in a
nutshell um yes of course of course
everyone is in a form of uh Jihad in the
context of you know like you said a
woman who has given birth yes but what
I'm trying to say is this year is that
in the in the context what we're trying
to say is that a man who is look at it
look when you when your husband gets
another wife
you're not today like you're not going
to die yeah you're not going to
physically die number one number two
he's coming back home to you number two
he provides for you for protects the
same man is coming back to you when I go
to war and I die I'm not coming back
I'm not coming back
I'm not coming back you're coming you're
coming back I'm coming back home to you
but when you're sharing me it's another
a woman but in the context when I'm
going to walk I ain't coming back but
I'm gone you know what that's why I
believe Allah told us men about Quran
aim by the way if you guys know that
we're going to have in Jannah inshallah
yeah
we're gonna have you know why because if
you think about it guys guys one second
we'll finish that guys why why guys guys
why does Allah told us men about and
they are described in a very very
specific manner why because Allah
created us he knows our weaknesses he
knows what we want a simple people why
isn't going into details what women are
going to get you know why because if
Allah said you're going to get one
Palace and one bag he will say oh but I
want 10 palaces so Allah doesn't go into
details but when it comes to the man bro
very simple what Elaine thank you all
day every day brother
I wanted to say yeah
so what I'm saying is this year but
that's why the incentive for a man who's
going to war knowing he's going to die
and not come back to his wife he has the
incentive of hurling
all day every day
so this is just a disclaimer you're very
quickly a disclaimer I agree with what
hijab was saying from an ideological
point of view
um I also agree with what you were
saying about the intention behind it but
I feel like this is the problem the way
we discuss this uh Topic in the first
place to me as an outsider just
listening to both sides it seems a bit
like Tit for Tat oh
and in this it's just understand it no
no it's tough for attack but it's not
understanding because understanding you
know what the sister what the sister
said the way I would have responded I
would have said look sister first of all
you said it's about desire
right no she said yeah yeah she said
yeah and and so what
exactly so what it is about desire I'll
be honest yes if a man thank you if a
man a man if a man has desire to fulfill
that and he wants to multiply in the
land yeah and he wants to build families
because
we are Muslims the moment the man gets
married again what he does is he he he
he he generates he needs to generate
extra energy to fulfill to be a father
twice to be a husband twice to be a
provider twice and that so it's not that
the desire is uh something dirty it's
that we're curtailing the desire in a
way that is pleasing to Allah thank you
may Allah bless you inshallah guys we
need to wrap up if you want part two
yeah may Allah bless our honorable
sisters here our honorable sisters there
our honorable Brothers all the way there
uh for uh having a part in this
inshallah and may Allah bless you guys
till next time you want part two no
problem comment in the section below
until next time from the bitty trip show
assalamu alaikum
will build for
him where Allah tells us that our books
will be given and every little active
weight of God will be there and imagine
you see a mountain and what a lucky
person which righteous person
and Allah says this is for you for me
yes what did I do you allowed people to
pray you built a Masjid I've never had
the money to build a master to Allah you
helped you gave towards it and Allah
gives you the reward of as if you've
built it don't let it now guys and do
not delay and share the video for extra
Rewards
foreign
[Music]